This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. This episode was listener requested. Actually, it was requested a lot of times, a lot of times. And,
And as with all listener requested episodes, I always am like, how have I never done this before? Because when you start thinking about it, a lot of us live with shame about who we are and we carry that in silence. We are ashamed each of us, I think, of something in our lives, of our past, our past mistakes, maybe our bodies, our choices, our identity, our entire personhood. at times. And that shame takes over quite literally everything. It can become a constant companion in everything that we do so that when we wake up, we feel like we aren't good enough. When we want to take a risk or do something brave, we can't trust ourselves. When good things happen to us, we think we don't deserve them. Shame is above all else, at its core, at its beginnings, it's a social or moral emotion. That's what it was, what kind of evolved.
to be. We feel it very intensely in situations where we believe that we have upset, offended, disgusted someone, or when we go against some social norm or moral held by society that means that perhaps we deserve to be punished, outcast, we are unworthy of acceptance and forgiveness. This is what makes it a deeply painful emotion that seems so hardwired into our social brains. It's a way to make us behave, make sure that we are good boys and girls, and also that we hide behavior that we think others will judge us for. We hide ourselves away altogether when we think that our mistakes or something about us makes us unsavory as a whole, not worthy of being seen. This is the problem with chronic shame. It's that we don't just feel this emotion in response to specific circumstances because that would be guilt.
We feel shame even when we are alone, even when there is no audience, there is no offensive behavior that we have committed. And that is the kind of shame that I want to discuss today. Toxic, chronic shame that just doesn't accompany a hiccup or small mistake, but which kind of ends up feeling like part of our DNA. And that's what it means to be shame bound. And it's one of the big battles that a lot of us have to overcome in our 20s. is to be released from this very oppressive force that keeps us small. And that is what shame does.
Shame keeps us small because it becomes self-imposed. At some point, we don't need another person to give us a dirty look or to humiliate us or to expose us, reject us. All of those things, we end up doing them to ourselves in a way as a way to stop us from being critiqued and seen. and because we almost anticipate that if we were to show up and try hard and be visible, someone is going to find something about us that we deserve to be ashamed of. I don't think that it will come as a surprise that, sadly, this pattern has a lot of roots in trauma, and not just the big trauma that we think of,
but small moments where we were made to feel terrible and disgusting because of part of who we were. So let's talk about it today. I want to really discuss how shame gets implanted in our self-concept, what that feels like, what that does to our ambition, what that does to our direction, but also some of the best advice I have encountered in a long time on how to release ourselves from being shame-bound. I know this is something that a lot of us live with for different reasons. and we're going to discuss those as well.
But I really hope that if the thing, what you might actually realize is that the thing that is keeping you from, everything you might want, everything that you could be, is not a lack of effort. It's not because you're lazy. It's not because you don't know what you want. It's not because you're not capable.
It's because of an inherent shame that you feel around being seen and being loud and being heard. So, without further ado, let's discuss the psychology of shame. Brunay Brown is one of my favorite, favorite researchers, people in general, and in her very well-known TED Talk, which is called The Power of Vulnerability, it was released almost 14 years ago. It's incredibly popular. It's a must watch. She says that shame is essentially the fear of disconnection, and it sits very closely besides, our fear of loneliness, of judgment, ostracization, and social pain.
Because basically, it is posing a very insidious and toxic line of questioning. Is there something about me that if other people were to know or were to see, they would believe I wasn't worthy of belonging? And if there is, I better hide it or else how could I be loved and accepted? There is this kind of toss-up in our brain. Either I can be truthful, open, I can be myself. and maybe I won't ever be loved or I can be secretive and I can conceal who I really am and maybe I can be loved. Those in our mind when we are shame bound are the only two options.
We never once think, well, maybe the things I'm ashamed of others would just see as part of me. That would just be something that they love and that they would nurture. That's not how chronic shame works. It's a very limited belief that if you are unworthy in some ways, you better be hiding that part of yourself. This results in a number of really, really unfortunate, unhappy behaviours and compulsions, like the need to self-isolate. If you've ever found yourself, you know, self-isolating after a big social event and you, and you don't think that you're an introvert or hiding away after like a really long, exhausting day in front of people or after a big presentation or after you've spoken your mind,
feeling the need to be silent. Maybe that comes from shame. There's also an intense embarrassment or anxiety in social situations. There is a self-loathing. There is a self-sabotage, feeling of rejection, all of which stop us from attempting anything that might make us feel seen, because that is what shame does. It's a minimiser. Literally, think about the physical actions and behaviors, the physicalities that accompany feeling shame. Think about the last time that you were like, oh my gosh, I feel ashamed. You were probably not making eye contact. You were slouching your shoulders, lowering your head, almost curling into yourself. Physically, socially, mentally, shame's goal is to shrink us. The opposite of shame in that sense is self-acceptance, accepting who you are, your body,
your identity, how you've gotten here, even if you have regrets, And that self-acceptance, that self-confidence. That is what makes us expansive, self-assured creatures, passionate, outspoken, loud about life creatures. And that's the goal here. That's the direction that we want to move in. But before we get there, I do need to give you a few more crucial details about the pathology and the underworkings, underpinnings of shame.
So shame is universal. I know it feels like quite a solitary experience. That is the nature of it. But the only people on this planet who don't experience shame are those who have essentially no human empathy. They have no desire to be liked or be seen or accepted by others. So we might call these people psychopaths, right? And a few studies have found a very strong association between psychopathy and low shame-proneness, which basically means that even if you were to do something that is like objectively wrong and immoral,
you still don't feel bad about it. There was a really fascinating case study that I dug out of the archives when I was looking into this. And it's on a man, this unnamed man, who was in prison in the US. And he had admitted his crime, his crime was armed robbery and actually resulted in someone being murdered. But even years later, he felt no remorse at all. He felt no shame.
He believed that he was justified because of how he was raised. And when he was in prison, he continued to steal, to live. lie to do interviews where he almost bragged about his crimes, whatever he could, to basically get his way, even when it meant others were hurt, all because of that, you know, that part of us that that lights up when we hurt, we injure, we upset someone else, our shame center, his basically wasn't working. And that's kind of the alternative that we're working with. Shame is also very different to guilt. I know they are sometimes used interchangeably, but guilt, I actually believe it's adaptive. You know, it is tied to a specific situation in which we have done something
objectively wrong. We've made a mistake and we can say, you know, I feel guilty for how I've acted because I've messed up, I've hurt someone. And that acknowledgement of a specific instance in which we have gone against our own, kind of our own expectations for ourselves, our own standards, that makes us a better person. We bring ourselves back in line. Shame, on the other hand, it does not make you a better person. At no point is shame going to make you better. In fact, it's just so incredibly destructive because it rests on the premises that it's not just that we sometimes make mistakes, is that our whole sense of self, we are a mistake.
We are wrong. Even when we have no evidence for that, even when it's not situation specific like guilt. Oftentimes, when you feel shame, you'll begin to notice that no one's even around. You haven't hurt anyone. You are a good person. There's nothing that you can think of, but you still feel this deep sting just by existing. Also, I think the other key point here that I didn't mention before, guilt actually has somewhere to go, right?
You know, we can rectify our mistakes, we can apologize, it can motivate good behavior. Shame lingers. It doesn't exit. It just implants deeper and deeper within us. Something really important to remember is that, no matter how long you have carried your shame, no matter how long you and shame have shared the same home, been companions, none of us were born ashamed of who we are. At some point, and this is a sad thing to say actually, someone had to teach you that there was
something about how you look, how you act, your identity, your existence that was offensive to them and that shouldn't be seen. think about the shame that a lot of people used to associate with being queer, with being part of the LGBTQIA plus community. At some point, someone said something really demeaning to you, or maybe someone's parents said that they would be ashamed to have a queer son or a queer daughter. Or, you know, you see things in the media that just villainize people who are literally just living their life. That is leading, probably led a lot of people to internalize that therefore they are shameful and that is not the case. or the shame of making a mistake as a child and being criticized for so much more than the action, you know, instead of just your parents scolding you and saying,
I can't believe you spilled the milk, it's, I can't believe you are so clumsy, you are so lazy, you are worthless, you are useless. Can you see that shame is not about what you've done? It's associated with who you are. And how can any part of who you are be inherently shameful? It becomes implanted in our minds until the point where it is self-imposed. We end up using it against ourselves without ever needing anyone else to tell it to us again. I heard Dr. Pete Levine, he's a very well-known trauma doctor and trauma specialist.
Look him up if you're interested in this. But I heard him say in a video the other day that shame is like a cancer that grows from the injury of trauma and from the wound of betrayal, especially interpersonal trauma and interpersonal betrayal, which is basically the trauma we encounter from the transgressions and actions of others, especially people that we trust. And that cancer from these situations becomes deeply lodged in our bodies and our minds, and it affects and infects all other aspects of our life. Your relationships, how you show up at work, in class,
how you walk into a room, what you feel you deserve from your life, nothing remains untouched. So how do we get to this place? This doesn't just happen. How do we get here? Well, Dr. Levine, same guy, he suggested that there are two specific pathways through which we adopt chronic shame, or we become shame bound. The first is if you are traumatized or humiliated as a young child or a teenager, either by a parent, a sibling, a friend, a bully, a teacher, whoever it may be, someone trespasses against your sense of self-worth by harming you, by making you feel useless and small. And because of our limited critical thinking skills at the time or our limited life experience as children, the only way that we can make sense of what we're
experiencing is by internalizing what has happened, which causes us to basically assume that something must be fundamentally wrong with us. We lay the below. on our own innate badness because we have to assume that we are the cause. We are the common denominator because how else could we continue to trust people? How could we continue to trust people that we rely on like our parents, like our teachers, like our family? They must be right. This is actually part of what he proposes is a survival strategy.
We cannot possibly think that the people that we rely on for security and safety, would be wrong about things like this because then they could be wrong about other things and then, you know, who could help us? The other element of this occurring in childhood, especially is that all the people that we feel ashamed or feel shamed by are often older and wiser. And so we deduced that they must know something about our character that we don't. They are the truth holders. We have this big red cross on us. They must be correct. We are wrong and awful and bad because they told us that we were. The more experiences we have like this, the more difficult it is to deny our badness, the more oppressive and entrenched, the shame becomes. This can also be more pronounced
for people who, who's just identities in general criticized by a very oppressive, dominating, prejudice society. We do see higher rates of internalized shame in the queer community, amongst people of color amongst people in marginalized religions because there is this system that says and there is just you know it's held up by the media it's held up by discrimination by prejudice by stereotypes that essentially says we don't really like you that much and there's no reason that we don't like you there's just some part of you that's wrong and it's just so awful that children from a very young age begin to pick that up shame i really want this to be very apparent shame is not dispersed equally across society.
The second way that chronic shame develops can come about a little bit later, and it really comes down to a fear of being left out, which feeds off, again, our fear of loneliness, and our fear of being excluded, very human primal fears. I don't think I have to tell you, hopefully, I don't have to tell you that community and belonging are so important. They're just literally our lifeblood. It's one of our foundational,
psychological needs and not just a physical need but an emotional need as well. There's a really well-known study using fMRI technology, which is basically a machine that shows us which parts of our brains are active when we're doing certain things. And it examined the brains of people who were made to feel lonely, disconnected and rejected versus the brains of participants who are made to feel accepted, included and connected. The brain scans of the participants who were made to feel isolated, were just lighting up in the areas of the brain responsible for pain and perceiving danger, meaning that this experience of not being liked or welcomed was physically uncomfortable at times.
Now, if you know what that feels like to have people not like you, and to not only have them not like you, but to make that known, to be openly judged, you are going to work pretty hard to stop that from happening again. and here is where your shame seemingly to you feels useful because you're like, okay, if I listen to my shame, I'll never step out of line. If I listen to my shame, I'll never do something that's wrong. I'll be able to make friends. I'll be loved.
Anytime you go to, therefore, you know, there onwards, go to change anything about yourself, to put yourself out there, to bet on yourself to be authentic, vulnerable. That shameful voice comes in and. says, don't do it. Don't let yourself be seen. The more visible you are, the less safe we are, take a step back. That shameful voice, you think that it's acting as your protector. It's convincing you that it's keeping you safe from rejection and exclusion. But, you know, although our shame likes to masquerade as a form of self-preservation, it ultimately limits your ability to experience life, because it's keeping you tied down.
So that smallness is one of the consequences of letting shame be the loudest voice in the room. And that's actually how I like to think about it. It's the guy in class in your meeting who's always interrupting you. It's the voice that just doesn't know when to shut up. It's the voice that's saying, oh, well, actually this, well, actually that. Another real loss is that when you are shame bound, even when good things happen to you, you still don't believe that you deserve them. When someone listens, when someone lets us be vulnerable and accepts us, we never totally
accept it. We are waiting for the so-called emotional jump scare because our self-concept has been reprogrammed time and time again to assume the worst, to have our guard up, to cut ourselves down before someone else can. Actually, it's really interesting because it's really interesting and this is kind of a side note, but there has been some really cool fascinating research, not cool, but definitely fascinating research that shows that people who experience more shame often are quite obsessed with self-improvement because they are constantly trying to fix or fix something about themselves or to show that they
are deserving of things by working hard to change who they are. And so sometimes it's like, well, I can't have anything that comes easy because I don't deserve it. So there is something deeply, deeply wrong about me that if I focus on self-improvement, on getting really, really fit, on learning or making my life seem perfect, then I can prove that all these good things have actually worked hard for them. So quite an interesting, very interesting point of view, especially as someone who I'm like, ooh, I like work in the self-help, self-improvement space. I want people to get the most out of their life.
It's interesting how many of us might actually be doing that because of a shame of never being good enough. Chronic shame, I think this is very similar, is also reflected often in people pleasing because we, of course, prioritise the opinions of others over our own. We want them to stay happy with us, even if it means a loss of personal identity and less personal fulfillment. And shame can also lead to self-sabotaging behaviors where we consciously undermine our success or our happiness by procrastinating by neglecting opportunities, neglecting relationships, minimizing ourselves in front of others, or even engaging in really risky behaviors to confirm negative beliefs about ourselves because when you have lived that long in shame,
it feels like home. What's that quote? It's like, better the hell you know than the heaven that you don't. And that is where we're at. I think another element of it is also, you know, success. and doing well brings attention. And that spotlight might reveal even more aspects of us that we should be ashamed of. And we can't have that. So, you know, you go out and get drunk the night before a big meeting. You ruin the relationship before it can progress. And at least, you know, you already feel comfortable in that understanding of yourself.
You are a failure. You're not enough. You'll never deserve this. Can you kind of see what Dr. Levine was saying? It is a cancer. The way that shame manifests itself. it metastasizes into everything that we do. So what I want to talk about next is where we can go from here.
We've identified the problem. I think maybe I'm saying things to you and you're just nodding your head, being like, yeah, I already knew that. I've literally lived with this for years. What do I do about it? How do I be more big and vulnerable and authentic when I'm being told by my own brain to be quiet, small, invisible? Well, we are going to talk about all of that and a lot more after this short break,
so stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of Congress. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month,
I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know
when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now.
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Shame is kind of like a bad habit. It won't change unless you do.
And I'm not saying it won't change unless you get better and you prove it wrong. I mean that it's always going to feel like you're fighting with yourself until you accept it. until you, it's almost like when you lay back in the ocean and you just let it take you and you lie in it and you realize that you've been struggling against something for so long that if you just turned around and said, it's okay, I see you, I accept this. Maybe it would start to fade a little bit. The person, and I've already mentioned her once in this episode, obviously I am obsessed, but the person I always turned to for advice on this is Brunet Brown.
And obviously, Brunay Brown, she's made her career on shame, guilt, vulnerability. and the best thing she ever said about the shame cycle is that an actual bad person, a person who has done things they deserve to feel ashamed for, they would never sit down and question whether they are a bad person, they would never admit their mistakes. So the very fact that you were considering your worthiness is evidence in yourself that you are worthy. You are someone deserving of love. You have empathy. You are someone who is lovable, someone who can be forgiven. however big or large that mistake was.
And you are actually, it might sound surprising, you are someone who was enough, regardless of what makes you believe that is not true. So there are a few steps we can take to truly accepting that fact. First, don't let your shame be general. Force it to be specific. You know, this sounds very strange, but you see, one of the reasons shame is so good at convincing us that we're worthless is it takes a single instant of,
of embarrassment or a slip up or a thought, and it applies the feeling to everything. So instead of saying, you know, I feel bad because I said the wrong thing to my really good friend and I hurt them, I feel awful because I wish I was a better friend in that moment. Our shame takes that feeling and it removes a bunch of information and it concludes, well, I am bad. I am wrong. I am awful. Even after the situation has long passed.
that overgeneralization is what causes trouble. So instead, learn to add information back into the negative statements that you tell yourself. You need to realize that shame relies on you taking everything that it says truthfully and not interrogating how it could be so general. You know, are you a really a bad person always, without question, or are you just feeling bad? So I want you to replace the I am awful with, I'm feeling awful. I am wrong with, I'm just assuming that I'm wrong. I feel, I assume, I'm thinking that I am.
Use those exact words instead to kind of put some reality back into your faulty thinking. So let's use the example of a really common one. I am an unlovable person to kind of show how this works. Is this statement, I am unlovable, true? is it, you know, is it fact? Could you find this fact on Wikipedia? Has someone done a peer-reviewed experiment on this and come to you with a solid, you know, thesis, conclusion, hypothesis saying, yeah, this is, I've conducted, you know, millions of interviews and I did heaps of studies and, oh, by the way, yes, you are unlovable. Or, or is this an emotions-based conclusion? It's
emotions-based, right? It's coming from you. So I want you to replace I-M-A-Mobile. I-Mobile. I am with, I feel. I feel like an unlovable person. And then ask why? Is there something that has triggered this feeling? Is there a specific recent memory? Maybe there is. And you can add that in. I feel unlovable because of how badly that date went. I feel unlovable because that person didn't treat me well. That puts distance between you and the immediate like instinct to go to shame. you can kind of now see that this isn't something intrinsic about you. It's actually a feeling, not a fact, and it's about how someone else chose to treat you. That's a sign of their flawed character, not your own.
This is not a permanent fact. I just want to say that again. It's a momentary experience based on someone else's actions, not your inherent worth. The other alternative is that you may be searching for a recent memory way you've been made to feel this way. and you just can't find one. It's like no evidence. There's no reason why you should be feeling this way. And it must be based on something else.
And that thing that it's based on is shame. It's not a real statement. There is no evidence for why you should be feeling this way. It's just shame. That is what it is. Either way, when we rely on those I am broad statements, they are just incorrect because they are way too general. Next, I think it's really worthwhile to explore your shame and try and find an origin point.
Like, you know how every villain has an origin story? Your shame has an origin story as well. As I said before, you know, no one is born feeling, disgusting, undeserving, shameful. It's a learned behavior. It's a learned habit. And when we do the really hard autobiographical work of looking back through our memories and our past, often that becomes very, very clear, very quickly. You can see that there is a line between the thoughts and the feelings you have about yourself now
and the things your younger self encountered and internalized. I'm going to provide an example, my own example here. I think of all the shame that I have felt about my body for years, and it was so hard to even think of where that may have come from because my opinions of my bodies were just so hurtful to even touch. But when I reflected, I saw this very clear line in my memory, a before and after around a series of events. The first was a picture day when I was seven,
and I don't know if you remember this, but we did our big class photo. And I remember getting the photo and the boy, this boy said that it looked like a whale. I was wearing this little dress and I kind of looked at all the other girls and I was just like, oh my God, I'm bigger than them. Bear in mind, I was seven. Like, I wasn't, like, look at that. Now I feel the need to justify. I'm going to stop myself there. But I remember, like, taking the photo home and telling my mom that I was like, oh, there was a fan behind me.
It was blowing my dress up. That's why I have such a belly. It's really sad to think of now. But that's how I felt. And that was my first experience of shame. And then maybe a week later, I was at after-school care. And we were watching a movie. And I remember what it's called.
It was called The Little Princess. And a much older boy said to me, you know, you would look like her, meaning the main character, if you weren't so fat. And oh my God, I can still remember how I just had this like hot flush all across my face and my skin was like pringly. like, oh, just felt more, I wanted to hide. And that was the moment that I think I was like, oh, this is a new feeling. This is the feeling. This is shame. It's really kind of sad to relive those memories.
But the self-knowledge that came with that was so powerful, you know, to be an adult, knowing so much better now and kind of rethinking how I would have responded. I know I would have stood up for my seven, I think maybe seven or eight, old self. And so now, now that it's my own thoughts that are saying those cruel things, you look fat in that outfit, everyone is going to think so, you know, you should wear something more flattering, you should cover up. You know, that's my own voice now telling me those things. But I picture that voice as this 10-year-old boy. And I think, oh my gosh, what do you know? You're a child. Shut up. I'm an adult. You're 10. I'm the adult. I'm going to wear what I want.
So that's how I picture it. I picture it is the first voice that I heard it as. You know, when that shame was implanted in my brain, it was spoken as a 10-year-old and I think about him and, you know, he's a fucking kid. I don't need to listen to that. That's one approach. Or I also think about myself as a child, suddenly being very awoken to a world of judgment and unkindness and it must have been such a shock.
And I think how would my present adult self comfort her? if adult me had been in that building watching that situation ready to intervene what would I have done I would have pulled her aside and I would have said you have value no matter what anyone else thinks I think you are the most beautiful girl in the world and you deserve to love your body because it does so much for you look about look at how it takes care of you you don't need to hide for anyone especially not this boy and confidence is going to be your superpower and I would say those things when you are reflecting on those origins of your shame, consciously bring empathy, kindness, compassion back into those
memories. Because shame is so socially orientated. Often we think that we need others to approve of us in order to heal from it, but there is a lot of self-forgiveness that you can provide yourself. For me, it was about apologising to my younger self, forever believing that this person knew who I was, or forever believing that I needed to hide, forever believing that something was wrong about me. I've learnt that's not the case. And now I'm going to go forward and you're going to go forward, nurturing the part of you that still wants to withdraw
and instead showing up as this big protector, this big strong person, this adult who is going to defend you. We also want to practice the kind of unconditional love that we've always craved by showing it to ourselves. don't hide from the shame. In fact, speak it out loud. I'm ashamed of my past. I'm ashamed of who I am. I'm ashamed of my body. And yet, and yet, I choose to love myself anyways because I'm as deserving of love as anyone else. I love others unconditionally so I can love myself the same way. In fact, think about all the people who know and love you, not because they're forced to, but because they want to. They want to be by
your side. They have the freedom to be friends with anyone, and they are choosing with that freedom to love you. It's just a further proof of how brilliant you are. And wouldn't they love you even more? the more they saw of you? Reflect on your own relationships here. Doesn't your love only grow with more vulnerability? When someone shows you more of who they are, don't you just love them more? That goes both ways.
Finally, I want you to question what staying small out of shame, what's it going to get you? And is that actually your dream destination in life? What is the cost of staying small versus the benefit of staying safe shame is just fear and fear is something you don't have to listen to it's a fear of failure it's a fear of embarrassment of loneliness as we discussed before and when you have your last moments on this earth do you want to think oh i'm so glad i let myself be scared
that was a great decision or do you want to think i'm so glad i let myself be free i'm so glad i listened to the people that mattered and I ignored the rest. I'm so glad I let myself be authentic, vulnerable. I put myself out there. I took risks on myself. I just knew who the fuck I was. And I want a serious answer from you, because I do believe that you can overcome chronic shame if you see what waits on the other side. That is a very motivating thing. And for me, you know, it's just been, as we said, total acceptance. because why would I live my life based on what a mean voice says to me in my head? When that's not even my voice, someone else's voice that's just snuck in there. It's not welcome.
For me, that has really helped me build a courage to try anything and everything, even if it goes wrong. It's resulted in the ability to commit to my dreams because I deserve them. it's evolved into the capacity to accept love. And I really want that for you. It does make me quite sad to think of how many of us don't realize that the root of everything we don't like about ourselves is not the fact that those things aren't worthy. It's that we just feel shameful about them. And shame is not a fact, it's a feeling.
You know, the parts about yourself that you don't like, there is nothing inherently bad about them. It is that someone at some point has conditioned you, taught you, to feel that way. And I don't want you to feel that way anymore. So I hope that this episode has helped you understand the root of it, has helped you go back and discover the origin, discover the villain, the villain origin story. And I hope that you start treating that younger version of yourself with the kindness that you always deserved. And that includes treating your current self with the kindness that they deserve because you and that childhood self are not different. You're the same person. You're on the same timeline here. If you enjoyed this episode, make sure you're following along. Maybe share it with a friend,
share it with a parent, if they might need to learn this lesson. That's a bit audacious. Just hopefully it reaches the people that it needs to reach. That's all I'm saying. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology podcast. If you have further questions, queries, stories to be shared, please let us know. We would love to hear from you. We're also taking episode suggestions, just slide into our DMs and tell us what you want to hear about. Until next time, remember, stay safe, stay kind, and most importantly with this episode, be gentle with yourself. You don't deserve to live in shame. You don't deserve to be shame-bound, not one bit. And we will talk very, very soon.
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy,
appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, all. wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.